la france vous le savez est en pointe
dans cette nouvelle tentative
d'apaisement alain juppé le ministre
français des affaires étrangères est
arrivé ce matin dans la capitale
bosniaque après une étape vous l'avez vu
à zagreb en croatie
c'est la première visite de monsieur
juppé à sarajevo au même moment françois
léotard le ministre de la défense rend
lui aussi visite aux casques bleus
de son côté donc alain juppé doit avoir
des entretiens politiques avec le
président bosniaque
ajoutez à cela que le porte-avions foch
doit quitter toulon tout à l'heure dans
moins d'une heure à destination de la
mer adriatique pour renforcer les
bâtiments déjà en place autour de l'ex
yougoslavie à genève des négociations de
paix entre les trois partis qui se
déchire en bosnie ces discussions ont
pris un tour nouveau en fait le bras de
fer continue
et les serbes qui avaient menacé de
partir sont tout de même rester à la
table des négociations
olivier lerner à genève les grandes
manoeuvres de radovan karadic ont porté
leurs fruits
il menaçait teaser de quitter la table
des négociations et s'il est encore là
ce matin en chair et en os c'est qu'il a
bien obtenu satisfaction
sous l'égide de l'onu une commission
denquête devrait donc se pencher
rapidement sur le massacre de sarajevo
des officiers de liaison serbes croates
et musulmans mèneront également l'
enquête
problème les musulmans bosniaques sont
curieux comme les approuver la
commission comme en baisse commission
d'investigation ou dépens que les serbes
n'en font pas partie ça va me comprenait
oui mais le problème c'est que les
serbes font partie de la commission
radovan karadic compte bien se blanchir
aux yeux du monde
avec cette commission d'enquêté
remercions le secrétaire général de
l'onu d'avoir formé cette commission et
qui admet une participation serbe après
l' enquête
les choses seront plus claires vous
verrez pour la communauté internationale
en séance plénière ce matin croates
serbes et musulmans aborde aujourd'hui
le chapitre de la démilitarisation de
sarajevo puis si tout va bien ils
tenteront de dessiner une nouvelle carte
de la bosnie herzégovine qui serait
dit-on divisé en trois républiques
comprenant en tout 17 quand on voit si
ce nouveau découpage américains et
russes sont bien décidés à mettre tout
leur poids dans la balance pour tenter
de recoller au plus vite les pots cassés
deux émissaires américains envoyés par
bill clinton et un russe sont arrivés ce
matin
à genève effective